hey good humans before we get into this
episode of middle ground
here's a quick teaser of the leap that's
coming soon I'm about to call my dad
my ex-boyfriend did you love me you're
the one who told me face-to-face that I
am no longer your daughter working you
up so stay on the lookout for that video
of the leap that's coming out soon and
if you want to challenge yourself and
reach out to someone to reconnect and
take the leap then click on the link in
the description below and now enjoy this
episode of middle ground there are
people making the argument that we
should end self isolation because a few
hundred thousand deaths is worth
sacrificing for the economy some people
would agree with that until it's their
mother who dies or their uncle or their
grandfather nearly a dozen other states
will start to ease their restrictions as
they slowly start the reopening process
may not come back at all there will be
coronavirus in the fold I can see the
emotional agony it causes in patients
and their family members restrictions
should have been put on the people that
are sick I don't think it's a good thing
for our economy or our country so I had
to layoff my employees we have no work I
believe that it violates our most basic
of civil rights I wouldn't say that I'm
necessarily anti self-isolation but more
so anti-government imposed
self isolation
do you think is that working with good
data is gonna allow the US government to
continue to make better decisions I'm
not able to work in my given profession
despite this I am Pro quarantine I own
my own practice but because of the
quarantine I've only seen patients two
times a week it might be hard to
understand why people would gather like
this while a deadly virus ravages
America what if there's your mother one
of your infant son or daughter gets sick
[Music]
my name is Cedric Jamie Rutland I'm a
pulmonary critical care physician in
Southern California and Newport Beach in
Riverside California and I am pro
self-isolation hi I'm Dagny I'm an
ophthalmologist I live here with my
husband I'm an expecting mom to be here
in Orange County California and I am Pro
self-isolation hi I'm Alex I live with
my boyfriend and another roommate in a
very small apartment and I'm pro
self-isolation my name is Austin I'm a
chiropractor I live here in Newport
Beach California I would consider myself
anti self-isolation
hi I'm Allie Marie I am a massage and
craniosacral therapist by trade but I'm
currently a stay-at-home mom and I'm
about 20 weeks pregnant and I am anti
self-isolation
hi I am Julia I live with my family here
in Texas I am anti self-isolation I know
somebody who has been infected with
ghovat 19 can they disagree us please
turn off their cameras
you
I know a physician colleague in New York
who was infected and actually is an
expecting mom but thankfully she's doing
okay and on the road to recovery I also
know someone from my neighborhood who
unfortunately passed away and he's
actually relatively young one old
partner of mine who's little younger
than me probably 34 or 35 who was
infected with Koba 19 his case was mild
I had another physician friend of mine
who was older probably about 55 or so he
was infected with kovaydin and I had to
take care of him I'll talk to a little
bit different point maybe one of my
co-workers here her father had a heart
attack but he was diagnosed with kovat
at the hospital and ultimately they were
told that Cova 19 killed the patient
when really it seems that the heart
attack and complications from
cardiovascular disease were ultimately
the issue the other health care
professionals in the group here I would
love to hear your opinion on that as far
as what you maybe heard about how
they're counting who qualifies as a
Kovach case and what the cause of death
was necessarily here's what we've
discovered when you look at these
patients that have Cova 19 is as a
result of the presence of the virus
within your blood vessels and your blood
stream it leads to the activation of the
coagulation system so their blood can
clot easier so we've seen heart attacks
we've seen strokes we've seen pulmonary
embolisms and so your point is
well-taken he died of a heart attack
yes but toven 19 is a significant risk
factor of coagulation the disagree AHS
can join the conversation now
I do want to talk about the antibody
test that they've started and the
extreme percentages that they have seen
there was the one that they did
randomized in California recently where
they were getting as high as 55% for all
I know I've had it my daughter and I
were sick for four weeks six weeks this
winner right now in Michigan Governor
Whitmer is calling for all essential
workers to be tested but there's no
antibody tests to go right alongside it
so my husband who is an essential worker
could go get tested comes back negative
what does he have to get a weekly test
now when he could have already added
this winner with us and just had very
mild symptoms I'd like to make a point
because I want the doctors in the group
chat to respond to this I have heard
that gating Cova does not mean you won't
get it again there have definitely been
cases in the US and outside showing that
those who recovered actually went on and
tested positive again for the virus so
that is a little bit concerning because
we were all kind of betting that once
you get infected you'd be immune that
previous assumption was based on what we
know from some older viruses from before
it just goes to show that we still don't
know a lot about this virus
the scare of the virus is overhyped
I think that the scare has been largely
driven by the media I know that
initially there were models that came
out of the Imperial College of London
that claimed that millions of people
would die that was really used as the
justification for these massive
lockdowns and we have not seen those
numbers pan out at all I totally agree
with you that a lot of what we're seeing
is media created hysteria there's a lot
of new information that's coming out we
really think people were trying to do
their best with the data that they were
provided at the time I especially have
an issue with how the data is actually
being collected and then ultimately how
the deaths are being counted
since we initiated social distancing
especially when you look at California
you can see that the amount of
infections has slowed and I actually saw
this in the hospital I saw the uptake
and then all of a sudden as the governor
got more restricted and as the state got
more restricted in terms of isolation
you can see that California was
beginning to flatten the curve and
actually lead the nation in that I agree
with the self-isolation principle
because it did what it was supposed to
do which was prevent the amount of
infections to bombard the hospital
because that's not what you won I mean
we still have physicians getting
infected and the more infections you
have in the hospital the more likely it
is for one of us to get infected and
then you have a reduction of healthcare
workers to be able to manage these
patients someone called it even well
ahead of time if we find that weeks or
months from now the cases are not as bad
as projected people will say that we
overreacted when the truth is that's
just evidence that the things that we're
doing right now including self-isolation
has worked and for those people who
continue to compare you know Koba 19 to
really bad flu season well let's look at
the data they're saying that okay a bad
flu season we have 60,000 deaths in the
u.s. right now with over 19 we have
about 50,000 so it's comparable well we
have to look at the rate at which that's
happening that's in one year right now
we're in April and we're already
matching the worst flu season I do agree
the media is always biased but when we
have epidemiological and infectious
disease experts calling this a pandemic
calling this as something unprecedented
I think that's real and that is not hike
in terms of the hospital's being filled
to capacity that's obviously a situation
that nobody would want it appears to me
that the the US healthcare system didn't
become as swamped as they originally
predicted and I think that going back in
history quarantine tend to be for the
sick as opposed to the healthy and I
wonder if maybe we would take more of an
approach where the sick are being
quarantined which i think is is very
justifiable as opposed to everybody
who's healthy being quarantined that
might
be more appropriate the issue with that
is that we don't know who's sick
with SARS Cove 2 there are many
different estimations of how many people
are asymptomatic I myself have seen
people be asymptomatic that are positive
for the virus so that becomes an issue
at least with the Spanish flu you knew
who was sick and so until testing is
rampant throughout the country and we're
able to know who is asymptomatic I agree
with you quarantine II the people who
have SARS Cove - if we attest that
everyone is the most appropriate and
probably the single best treatment that
we can provide across the nation with
the United States our judicial system is
founded and rooted within innocent until
proven guilty now I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with us acting like we're
a carrier washing our hands using
antibacterial sanitizer but ultimately I
don't think it's right or fair for the
government to say you're not showing
symptoms but you could be sick so you're
gonna stay home it's like sending
somebody on trial to prison because they
could have been guilty this isn't like
putting people in prison because they're
sick I think this is actually more of a
political difference than like I guess a
medical argument there are people making
the argument that we should end self
isolation because a few hundred thousand
deaths is worth sacrificing for the
economy I disagree with that
some people would agree with that until
it's their mother who dies or their
uncle or their grandfather slowing the
curve is more important than human
rights during the quarantine
I guess I'll be the devil's advocate and
just I'm going to take I'm gonna take
issue with the framing probably a better
phrase would be civil rights perhaps
limiting people's ability to gather is
certainly an infringement on civil
rights but I would agree that the
actions that have been taken are worth
slowing the curb
everyone can attack me now there's no
attack advantage there's no attack and I
just wasn't gonna make a ridiculous like
extreme statement that's crazy so I'm in
Michigan where some of the most extreme
lockdowns have taken place Governor
Whitmer just today extended our stay at
home order 15 days but relaxed some of
the restrictions that everyone was so
mad about as far as you know there was a
huge Lansing protest recently operation
gridlock that was organized by the
Michigan conservative coalition that was
all about the fact that she was not
allowing all of these businesses to work
that were able to practice social
distancing some governors are willing to
go to whatever extent it takes because
it definitely has been an infringement
and like all of our civil rights to be
able to go out and in Harris County I
believe it's in Texas right that just
said that you'll be fined $1,000 if you
don't wear a mask in public the local
police union in Harris County actually
came out and said they will not be
enforcing that because they view it as
unconstitutional there's definitely a
balance there between federal overreach
versus states rights so California even
where you are is it's a very different
scenario in terms of the level of
outbreak the number of patients taking
kind of an individual approach I think
is important if you're in a state that
has seen very few cases I don't know
that the response needs to be the same
the federal government stepping in would
make it a one-size-fits-all and I don't
know that any of us would feel that was
appropriate I think that charging people
a thousand dollar fine for not having
face mask is classist and is regressive
whose less likely to have access to mask
it's poor people and they don't have a
thousand dollars to pay a fine I agree
that you know you have to find a fine
line between
an authoritarian response and something
that's responsible to all people I think
that the federal government and I'm
talking about both parties here I have a
lot of issues with both sides I think
they need to be taking a leading role
when you have disparate responses from
states what you risk is states with a
less extreme reaction or protocol you
you risk those people going across state
borders and actually spreading the virus
more and we don't want to get to a point
where we have to shut down state borders
the US government is handling the crisis
well
you
I am very torn on how I actually feel
about this my dad owns a small business
I've read a lot of the different
arguments on the payroll Protection Plan
and a bunch of the different deals with
Shake Shack and everything else which
there are a lot of details that go into
that 75% of any loan that's given to the
business owners has to be paid in to
employee benefits he has a company has
220 employees so you're talking 65
million in revenue every year and so
some would say his business is too big
he shouldn't have gotten it but that's
220 employees that he's taken care of
there can be an emotional response
saying they're not protecting the
mom-and-pop shops they're not protecting
this but ultimately 220 employees are
getting their salaries and 4 aren't and
while it's emotionally sad to see those
smaller businesses forced clothes we're
gonna be in a little bit over to
depression we're gonna hit a recession
and so we're all in this together and I
think the bipartisan support has been
really lacking especially in the
beginning but I think that they're
somehow finding away
so all I'm saying and I think it's
really simple is you have all this money
that we're giving to businesses and I
think it's appropriate and I think that
they should the issue is just testing
take some of that money and get give the
country some tests antibody testing and
the PCR testing so until that's done and
distributed across the country no I
don't think it's a job well done
can you tell me why that's such a
priority I know we need to know how many
people have it but can you explain to me
why that's so critical I just don't know
if we give everyone an antibody test
we're gonna know who the sick are i GM
is what gets produced acutely it's a
type of antibody in your bloodstream -
SARS cove - so you'll know who's
infected IgG means that you've had a
sustained response to the system and
your body has had enough time to develop
a neutralizing antibody so you'll be
able to quarantine the sick without
being symptomatic I haven't gotten my
stimulus checked yet I don't know about
anybody else my rent has already been
due where the hell is the check I
already need another check the
government to be focusing on helping
individuals who are stuck at home and
who have no way of surviving I think the
fact that the federal government the
White House specifically for months was
saying that this was a hoax and that
this was completely balana proportion
was hugely detrimental to our response
South Korea did a great job Taiwan did a
great job but unfortunately that is not
what I can say for the United States
things are turning around and all these
stimulus packages that they're doing the
fact that they're vowing to expand
testing is definitely on a better track
and my husband he was one of the first
in line when that cares package came out
to sign up for the forgivable business
loan and the PPP and he didn't get it
and it was heartbreaking to hear that
these large corporations were getting
access to that money so even though the
government was doing something of good
intent the way that it was executed
unfortunately wasn't the best dagi you
mentioned the South Korea admired South
Korea how their response was well to my
knowledge they had trackers on
everybody's cellular device that was
monitoring where they were going that
just in itself to me is a completely
asinine principle from the First
Amendment like the fact that government
is tracking your every
ooh seems a lot like house arrest the
tracker system that South Korea used has
generally been praised by most countries
and one of the main reasons that they
were avoid to able to able to avoid a
peek and have to implement quarantine
and we the u.s. are actually taking
lessons from them but it's not as
authoritarian as you think we all have
the option to opt out but the only way
this is going to work is if you opt in
and that's for people who decide that
the public good is of higher benefit
right now then our own individual I
guess concerns for privacy so
Dagny you're talking about different
countries and what they're seeing Sweden
never did a lock down they said if
you're vulnerable and at-risk stay home
don't go to work and their chief
epidemiologist right now is saying that
they are very close to reaching herd
immunity so within this whole idea of
staying home to avoid a second wave a
second wave is inevitable right now the
federal government recommendation on
when you can reopen your economy is if
you see a daily decline in positive
cases over two weeks and regardless of
how when those two weeks are it's gonna
start to rise again when everyone starts
being around each other
there is no negating it we can't stay
locked up in our houses for three four
five six months there's some doctors
saying that we're gonna still be seeing
coal good cases for 18 months when we
compared the u.s. to other countries I
think work we were more similar to the
tracks of Italy and China I don't think
her immunity works for every country
it's really gonna be specific to you
know the region itself I'm comparing
Michigan to Sweden because they both
have approximately 10 million people and
their population population density is
about the same and Sweden has a far less
death rate compared to Sweden
Dagny I feel like we have like the same
mind or something because I was just I
brought up this article about Sweden and
the situation there is very different
they have far more single person
households than the United States does
they have a much more robust social
safety net so people who want to opt out
of exposing themselves don't have to
worry about not paying their bills and
the Swedish government is actually
reconsidering their herd immunity
approach and considering taking stricter
because they're seeing the case in
Stockholm rise there are people in the
Swedish government who are saying they
might regret the herd immunity approach
and it is a much more homogeneous
society you know I hate to say but there
are societies that take more
responsibility to the health of like
everyone around them America is very
individualist country the log down is
harming my mental health
I have patients that are still coming in
so we get asked about this every day
like dr. Quan what do you think about
the lockdown what do you think's going
on I've not only been doing and working
my normal scheduled hours here at the
office but then we go home and I'll
spend hours and hours and hours and so
that we hours of the morning researching
trying to stay up on the new stuff
that's that's coming out on the
coronavirus so it has been very
fatiguing and toiling on me just being
able to take care of patients and do my
normal daily routine obviously no deaths
are discounted or lost or you know we
care about everybody who's dying and all
this but you got to look at like child
molestation rates that are going up
you're looking at spousal abuse rates
going up suicidal issues depression
anxiety overall lifestyle choices people
are making and especially mental health
concerns through this isolation is
definitely another factor that we're
looking at we might be stealing from
Peter to pay Paul this kind of idea when
it comes to you know we're we're looking
at the deaths actually occurring how's
my mental health been negatively
affected I feel like that would maybe be
stating it a little bit too strongly
some of you have mentioned we we appear
to be going the route of a depression
that's a scary thing it's really sad
it's gonna have a profound impact on
people's lives and this might be too
personal but I feel like ultimately
God's in control and I have to just you
know that's something that I have to
accept and and it gives me a little bit
of peace too I feel like not having a
lock down
we're probably affecting more because
it's the infection that scares me more
if I had to continue my normal patient
caseload and surgery caseload my
practice and be paranoid about every
patient thinking are they infected are
they going to inspect me and the fact
that our supplies our PPE is running
down as well in my own private practice
that would be more mentally straining to
me personally it's not that the presence
of all of these restrictions is not
harming my mental health it's just that
I feel that the restrictions are
appropriate my job
as a pulmonary and critical care
physician has changed forever I have to
now worry about kovat 19 in almost every
patient that I see because I'm a
pulmonologist and they present with
respiratory failure
and I have to be super protective and
super cautious when I'm dealing with an
out patient when I'm dealing with an
inpatient on called the ICU as I was
last night from here on out until the
vaccine comes or whatever and this is
something I have to do it because I have
two small little kids I have a
five-year-old a seven or a little girl
and I got my wife and I just feel that I
have to protect them I have felt judged
by the other side
if you oppose continued quarantine mass
quarantine I should say people judge you
and make the assumption that you don't
care about somebody's life
that's categorically not true I care
very much for people that are suffering
and people that are dying and I I don't
want for so that's what happened to
anybody
my sister-in-law specifically she was
not happy because I had said that
Whitmer was thinking about extending the
order 70 days and how I wasn't sure I
felt about it and I mean we're not even
actually on speaking terms right now
because she was so angry at me that I
would even potentially think that we
shouldn't all be quarantined by the
government right now as a doctor like I
truly believe I took an oath to protect
my community and to always have my
patients best interest in mind and to
really always be doing new innovative
research to look for new ways to help
take care of people this is just
something where now that I've seen what
I've seen I've looked at the data I've
done my own analysis and research on it
I've talked to some of the leading
experts in the field at this point and
there's enough evidence for me to go out
and protest for people who may not know
the data and may not really understand
some of that kind of stuff that's going
on this is a very interesting question
I'm sure you guys are surprised that I'm
here so most of my friends are in the
financial industry and so their
respective fields are suffering from
them what they say to me most often is
well you're a physician and your
business hasn't been affected and not
only that but for the first time in my
career instead of my presence being one
of relief it's without one of fear the
first thing of non-coated patient asked
me is were you in a kovat room earlier
today every time I make a right or left
I'm being judged
pretty lucky to say that I haven't
really been judged based on my position
because I think I'm actually in the
majority group in advocating for self
isolation I mean I've been judged on
plenty of other things being on social
media one of the things I recently spoke
up for was you know to end violence and
hate against Asian American people
descent because of this pandemic and I
think ultimately we're all on the same
page we all want what's better for the
greater good and you know to you guys
you think that is getting that economy
back up again if we hit it hard like we
are right now with the quarantine and we
continue to stay on track I think we all
ultimately get to go back to a normal
life faster I don't think Pro self
isolation means that were anti economy
I'm with you guys I want the economy to
open back but I only want it to happen
when it's safe to do so and that's just
based on you know objective data I have
learned something from the other side
there's the question do you mean in this
conversation or like in general in this
company Oh in this conversation okay I
[Laughter]
was like dang
I'm also an open-minded person and I
understand the frustration from both
sides is a nuance it's not a one or the
other issue technically I think that
there obviously is compromise that
should and can be made Dagny you said
something that I thought was pretty
profound being pro isolation doesn't
mean anti economy you know I'm guilty of
looking at the other side and thinking
you people just don't even care you've
said yourself you're having you know
your personal situation that has been
impacted and so so I really appreciated
that point that you made and then
getting a better understanding of where
you're coming from this is one of the
most pleasant conversations I have ever
had in terms of being able to discuss
politics science current events in a way
that was productive and so with that you
learn a lot from everyone who is
included what it shows to me is it shows
the model behavior that I feel like our
country should have in regards to how to
be productive about setting appropriate
restrictions setting appropriate
business opportunities for everyone and
I think it can be done I've learned so
much from you guys like I wrote it all
down actually and I'm gonna take it with
me put it here and use it next week I
feel like we're friends I enjoyed it
Austin DAGs once they lift these
restrictions we're all getting together
let's do it like this Ally
you
[Music]